In the Game of Thrones TV show, Euron Greyjoy
is a violent shit-talking pirate who wants
to “fuck the queen” and rule the world.
But in the book series, Euron’s a totally
different character – he’s a scary manipulative
murderer, a charismatic politician, and a
psychedelic sorcerer hungry for apocalyptic
power.
He’s got a magic dragon horn, and warlock
“slaves”, and Valyrian steel armour.
He’s connected to the mysterious magic of
Bloodraven, the Faceless Men, and Valyria.
Euron doesn’t just want a throne, he wants
cosmic eldritch power, and plans a blasphemous
blood sacrifice to make himself a Lovecraftian
god.
The fan community, especially Poor Quentyn,
theorise that Euron will bring apocalypse
to Westeros.
At the start of the story, Balon Greyjoy rules
the Iron Islands.
He rebels against the Iron Throne, and declares
the Islands his own separate kingdom – his
daughter Asha and his son Theon attack the
north.
Balon also has three brothers.
Victarion is a warrior – he’s strong and
loyal and kinda stupid . Aeron is a priest
of the Drowned God.
He used to be a party boy, until he was born
again as a religious man.
And then there’s Euron Crow’s Eye.
Euron was exiled from the Islands years ago,
and has since been sailing far-distant seas
in his infamous pirate ship, the Silence – its
crew are mutes, with their tongues ripped
out.
Its sails are black, and its decks are painted
red to hide the blood that soaks them.
The Silence is feared all across the east,
from Ib to Asshai.
But Euron doesn’t appear in the story right
away – he’s introduced slowly, like the
monster in a horror movie, with just rumours
and memories to build tension and mystery
– “men say terrible things” of Euron
Greyjoy.
Victarion and Aeron hate and fear Euron – Aeron
thinks “the storm is coming”, “and its
name is Euron Crow’s Eye”.
In Book 3, King Balon suddenly dies – he
falls to his death from a bridge on Pyke.
And the very next day, Euron returns after
years away, and claims Balon’s throne.
It’s very suspicious, so Asha thinks that
Euron murdered Balon.
In the TV show, Euron does straight up murder
Balon, but in the books it’s more complicated.
Arya meets a witch called “the ghost of
High Heart”, who makes a bunch of accurate
predictions and prophecies.
And the witch sees “a man without a face”
on a bridge that sways and swings.
On his shoulder perches “a drowned crow
with seaweed hanging from his wings”.
Presumably, the “man without a face” is
an assassin of the Faceless Men, and the “drowned
crow” is Euron “Crow’s Eye” – meaning
that Euron hired a Faceless Man to kill Balon.
Hiring a Faceless assassin is expensive, especially
if the target is an important person, like
King Balon.
But it’s implied that you can pay the Faceless
Men with something other than money, if you
sacrifice something that’s important to
you.
Euron claims that he once had a dragon egg.
He tried to make it hatch, but got frustrated,
and threw the egg in the sea.
Dragon eggs are super valuable and rare, so
would Euron really throw one away?
Some fans believe that Euron actually gave
the egg to the Faceless Men as payment – so
that they would throw Balon in the sea.
One way or another, Euron secretly hired a
magical assassin to murder his own brother.
But publicly, he hides his evil behind a charismatic
persona.
The real Euron is “hidden”, which is symbolised
by Euron’s eyepatch.
His right eye is described as his “smiling
eye”, the charming, swaggering, magnanimous
side.
But the eye behind his eyepatch is his “blood
eye”, where he hides his full cruelty and
sorcery and ambition.
By the time the ironborn see Euron’s true
face, it’s too late.
After King Balon dies, the ironborn hold a
“kingsmoot” to choose a new king.
And Euron uses a combination of politics,
murder, and swag[yolo] to win the [driftwood]
crown.
He rolls up in his infamous ship the Silence,
with an entourage of “mutes”, “monsters”
and “wizards” from the east.
He hands out treasure from his years of piracy,
bribing some rivals , and murdering others.
He makes grandiose speeches about how badass
he is – how he’s raided, raped and looted
all over the world , which is the kind of
thing the ironborn respect [as qualifications
for office].
In his election speech, Euron says he’ll
make the Iron Islands great again, evoking
their glorious past as “conquerors”.
He shows off his magic horn, Dragonbinder,
and says it has the power to bind dragons
to his will.
Euron plans to sail across the world to Meereen,
and to steal Daenerys Targaryen’s dragons,
and use them to take over Westeros.
It’s a totally crazy plan, so naturally
the ironborn love it, and make Euron their
king.
Euron leads the ironborn to conquer some nearby
islands, cementing his power by giving them
some glory.
But privately, Euron doesn’t care about
these islands, or the ironborn – he cares
only about himself, and everyone else is just
a means to an end.
Euron wants “The world”, he wants dragons
and “Woe”.
And he wants to marry Daenerys – “When
the kraken weds the dragon … let all the
world beware”.
So Euron sends his brother Victarion with
Dragonbinder to fetch Daenerys.
Victarion hates Euron because years ago, Euron
had sex with Victarion’s wife.
Then, because of Victarion’s fucked-up male
pride, Victarion beat his wife to death – this
is why Euron was exiled.
So Victarion agrees to sail east, but he secretly
plans to take Daenerys for himself, as revenge
for Euron taking his wife.
But Euron knows all about Victarion’s resentment,
and he exploits these feelings to manipulate
Victarion.
Victarion’s like a “puppet” – “blind
to the tentacles that grasp” him.
So he’ll probably fail to outsmart Euron.
We’re told that Dragonbinder brings dragons
not the person who blows the horn, but to
the horn’s true “master” – and Euron
is the master here.
So one way or another, it looks likely that
Victarion will die so that Euron can get at
Daenerys – Euron might steal the dragon
Viserion, like the Night King does in the
TV show.
So this is how Euron operates – he exploits
peoples’ hopes and fears to make them his
slaves in his quest for power and woe.
Euron uses and abuses his family, and his
people – and now he wants the world.
But how did Euron Greyjoy, an ironborn reaver,
become obsessed with dragons and world domination?
How did Euron become the “Crow’s Eye”?
Euron says that when he was a boy, he dreamed
that he could fly.
When he woke, his maester said he couldn’t
fly.
But what if he lied?
Maybe we all can fly.
“How will we … know unless we leap from
some tall tower?”.
This story is almost identical to how Bran
Stark discovers magic.
When Bran is a boy, he falls from a tall tower.
Then he dreams that he can fly – the “three-eyed
crow” visits his dream, and opens Bran’s
third eye to his magic.
When Bran wakes up, he can’t fly, his maester
says he can’t learn magic.
But the maester is wrong, and Bran learns
magic from the three-eyed crow, aka Bloodraven,
who is way creepier in the books.
So these flying dream stories are too similar
to be a coincidence – Bloodraven is called
three-eyed crow, and Euron is called the Crow’s
Eye.
Bloodraven has “one red eye”, and Euron’s
sigil is one red eye, with crows.
So the theory goes that Euron, like Bran,
was visited in his dreams by the three-eyed
crow.
In Bran’s dream, he sees “the bones of
a thousand other dreamers”.
So it looks like Bloodraven has tried out
a bunch of potential students, but most failed
or died.
Maybe Euron was one of those students.
Maybe when Bloodraven visited Euron’s dreams,
he saw how crazy and cruel Euron is, and decided
not to teach him magic.
But the damage was done – Euron went rogue
with his third eye opened.
Bloodraven and Bran are greenseers, with the
power to skinchange – to enter the mind
of another creature.
We don’t know if Euron has that power, but
it would make sense if he did.
Cause Euron gives Victarion a mute “dusky
woman” to go east with him, and fans speculate
that she’s spying for Euron – like maybe
Euron is skinchanging into her from afar,
to see what Victarion’s up to.
Skinchanging a human is seen as an evil abominable
act – so it’s exactly the sort of thing
Euron might do.
Skinchanging might also explain how Euron
controls his mute crew on the Silence – like,
how else could you co-ordinate the crew of
a ship if they can’t talk?
And skinchanging isn’t just a Stark thing
– we’re told that some ironborn skinchange
into sea creatures.
So Euron might just be a skinchanger.
Bran and Bloodraven can also magically enter
peoples’ dreams – and after Euron says
he’ll marry Daenerys, Daenerys has a creepy
sex dream of a man with “blue” “bruised”
lips – Euron has blue bruised lips because
of a drug he takes, so that’s probably him
in her dream.
Euron also enters Aeron’s dream, later on.
So it’s just speculation, but Euron might
secretly have the magic powers of a greenseer.
Either way, a visit from the three-eye crow
could explain Euron’s motivations.
In Bran’s flying dream, he sees “The whole
world” “spread out below him” – he
sees Winterfell and Asshai, sees dragons,
and “the heart of winter”.
Maybe Euron saw the same things – and when
he saw dragons and magic and the whole world
spread below him, he wanted it all.
Euron tasted godlike magic power, and will
stop at nothing to get more.
Euron travels to some of the most magic and
mysterious places in the world.
He says he “sailed to Asshai by the Shadow”,
right at the edge of the map, and saw “wonders
and terrors beyond imagining”.
Lots of the most powerful sorcerers in the
story learned magic in Asshai – Melisandre,
Quaithe, Marwyn, Mirri Maz Duur.
Asshai is like Hogwarts for edgelords – full
of “shadowbinders” and “bloodmages”
casting dark spells in the night”.
And right by Asshai is Stygai, the mysterious
“heart of darkness” where even shadowbinders
fear to tread – maybe Euron dared to enter
the “corpse city”, and found some evil
power there.
Euron also says he sailed to Valyria – the
smoking demon-haunted ruins of the ancient
dragonlords.
People say it’s impossible to visit Valyria
and survive, but Euron does have that Valyrian
steel armour and that Valyrian horn.
The old Valyrian empire used dragons and slavery
to conquer the world – which might have
inspired Euron to do the same thing.
So it seems that after Euron dreamed he could
fly, he travelled the world in search of magic
power, and developed his ambitions for world
domination.
And at some point, Euron captured some warlocks
from Qarth.
The warlocks had just been defeated by Daenerys,
and they were out to get revenge.
But Euron captured them, and took their shade
of the evening.
Shade of the evening is a psychedelic drug,
that gives visions of pasts and futures.
Euron gets really into the shade, to the point
where it stains his lips blue and bruised.
Euron says the shade opens his eyes, that
there’s “more truth in it than all the
gods of earth”.
Euron believes that gods and morality are
lies – and he commits horrific crimes just
to prove that no god can stop him.
It’s revealed that Euron murdered three
of his own brothers – as well as Balon,
he killed Harlon and Robin Greyjoy when they
were young.
The ironborn see kinslaying as the most evil
crime.
So after Euron choked the life from Harlon,
he “pissed into the sea”, waiting for
a god to strike him down, and “None did”.
“gods are lies”, he says, and “Men are
meat” – by breaking the laws of gods and
men, Euron feels like a god himself.
So Euron constantly mocks and perverts everything
that people believe in – he kinslays, blasphemes,
breaks every taboo just cause he can.
It turns out that the reason why Aeron is
so afraid of Euron is that when they were
young, Euron sexually abused him.
Euron says he taught Aeron how to pray, cause
Aeron would pray in terror when Euron came
to “visit” in the night.
Euron learned that sadistic cruelty gets him
worship.
When he terrorises the east in the Silence,
murdering and raping, men “pray”.
And so, Euron says, he is ”the godliest
man ever to raise sail”.
If “All gods are lies”, Euron decides
to become his own god.
And to become a god, he needs blood.
The Forsaken is a chapter from the upcoming
Winds of Winter, read at a convention by George
Martin – and it’s one of the darkest most
terrifying chapters in the series.
Euron imprisons Aeron, and tortures him physically
and psychologically.
He forces him to drink shade of the evening,
and Aeron has nightmarish visions of dead
brothers and dead gods.
Euron appears and says “These are the last
days, when the world shall be broken and remade.
A new god shall be born from the graves and
charnel pits”.
Euron’s hidden “blood eye” is finally
revealed, in all its horror and ambition – “I
am your king”, he says.
“I am your god”.
After the vision, we see Euron imprisoning
priests of all different religions – as
well as Aeron, he has priests of the Seven,
with their tongues ripped out.
He has a red priest, with a burned-off face.
He rips the legs off a warlock.
And he has this girl Falia – Euron seduces
her, and impregnates her, and says she’ll
be his wife, and she’s happy and excited,
but then Euron rips out her tongue.
Euron ties Falia and Aeron and the priests
to the front of his ships, as Euron and the
ironborn sail into battle against an enemy
fleet.
“blood is power” – in this world there’s
magic in death and sacrifice – so Euron
plans a blasphemous massacre of unimaginable
scale.
This battle will kill his imprisoned priests,
and his brother, and kill Falia and their
unborn child, it’ll kill the enemy fleet,
and his own fleet in a catastrophic orgy of
death – Aeron dreams of ironborn ships “burning
on a boiling blood-red sea”.
This carnage might “summon krakens from
the deep” – In Aeron’s vision, krakens
come at Euron’s command.
And we’re told that krakens can be drawn
to the water’s surface by blood – these
visions show a blood-red sea.
But Euron wants this massacre to make him
a god.
He knows that death and fear give him power
and prayers.
He knows there’s magic in the “holy blood”
of priests, and in the king’s blood of his
unborn child.
This battle is a giant blood magic ritual
– Euron will gorge on the deaths of thousands,
to transform into a terrible godlike being
– Moqorro sees “A tall and twisted thing
with one black eye and ten long arms, sailing
on a sea of blood”.
Aeron sees Euron as “no longer human”,
“more squid than man”, “his face a mass
of writhing tentacles” – so basically
Cthulhu.
Maybe the Drowned God that the ironborn worship
is actually an eldritch monster, and Euron’s
blood sacrifice will wake it from ageless
slumber.
Or maybe Euron really did throw that dragon
egg into the sea, and all this magic blood
will make it hatch into a monstrous sea dragon.
There is all sorts of crazy scary imagery
here, and it’s not clear what exactly will
happen – but there will be death and horror
and blood which Euron thinks will give him
the godlike power to break and remake the
world.
And it’s hinted that he’ll use this power
against the city of Oldtown.
Euron’s close to Oldtown now, and his ironborn
have been raiding towards the city.
Melisandre has a vision of “towers by the
sea, submerged beneath a black and bloody
tide”, “rising from the depths”.
It makes sense that Euron would want Oldtown,
because it’s full of secret magic.
Oldtown’s Hightower is built on an ancient
foundation of strange black stone, which some
say was built by a Lovecraftian fish people
called Deep Ones, which connects to the Cthulhu
stuff.
Oldtown has the Citadel, the university of
the maesters, which holds magic Valyrian artefacts
called glass candles.
A Faceless Man just infiltrated the Citadel,
possibly searching for a secret “blood-soaked
tome” called “The Death of Dragons”.
The city is ruled by Leyton Hightower and
his Mad Maid, who for the last ten years have
stayed in the Hightower, “consulting books
of spells”, possibly to “raise an army
from the deep”.
Oldtown is a powder-keg of dormant magic powers
just waiting to explode into an eldritch clusterfuck
– and Euron’s coming for it with a lit
match, “sailing on a sea of blood”.
And the most dangerous power in Oldtown, the
one that could spark apocalypse, might be
in the hands of Sam Tarly.
In the books, there are legends of the Horn
of Winter, an ancient artefact with the power
to destroy the Wall.
Mance Rayder claims to have the Horn, but
that turns out to be fake.
So “where is the true horn?”
In Book 2, Jon finds an old horn.
He gives it to Sam, who takes it to Oldtown.
Sam and Jon don’t think this horn’s important,
but the books keep subtly reminding us that
Sam has it.
So fans suspect that Sam’s horn at Oldtown
is the Horn of Winter, with the power to bring
down the Wall, and let the white walkers in.
Euron might want the white walker apocalypse
– he says wants to break the world, and
the Forsaken chapter’s full of apocalyptic
imagery.
Euron may have learned about the white walkers
in his flying dream, just like when Bran sees
“the heart of winter” “at the end of
the world”.
It’s said the white walkers will bring a
Long Night that never ends.
And Euron’s often described in terms of
night and darkness – his hair is black as
a “midnight sea”, his sails are black
as a “starless sky”, he says “we shall
feast before the fall of night”.
At the kingsmoot, Euron’s dragon horn sounds
three times – at the Night’s Watch, three
horn blasts means white walkers are coming.
Euron may be the harbinger of apocalypse.
According to eastern legend, the first Long
Night was caused by the Bloodstone Emperor.
And this ancient Emperor is very similar to
Euron.
The Emperor murdered his older sibling to
take her throne – just like Euron murders
Balon for his throne.
The Emperor practiced “dark arts”, “torture”,
slavery, and cannibalism, just like Euron
practices dark arts, torture, slavery and
cannibalism.
The Emperor “cast down the true gods”,
like Euron mocks and attack the gods.
And the Emperor worshipped a creepy black
stone – just like the ironborn throne, and
the Hightower foundation, and the city of
Asshai are all made of creepy black stone.
--The Bloodstone Emperor married a “tiger-woman”(?),
which might be kind of like Euron wanting
to marry the dragon-woman Daenerys.
The sister who the Emperor usurped was called
the Amethyst Empress, and as Euron points
out, Daenerys’ “eyes are amethysts”.
Euron’s hidden eye is called his “blood
eye”, which fits with the Bloodstone Emperor.
So there are lots of strong connections between
Euron and the Bloodstone Emperor, the guy
who caused the first Long Night, when the
walkers came for the first time.
It’s all happening again.
Rodrik the Reader warns that “history is
a wheel”, and “What has happened before
will … happen again”.
Euron is the Bloodstone Emperor reborn, a
figure so addicted to power and blasphemy
that he’ll bring darkness to the world.
Fan theorist Poor Quentyn writes that Euron
will climb the Hightower in Oldtown – another
“tall tower” – and will sound the Horn
of Winter, breaking the Wall, bringing the
Night, and sparking the apocalypse.
And after the storm, there’ll be silence.
The Game of Thrones book series is called
A Song of Ice and Fire – lots of Martin’s
stories are named after songs, because songs
to him represent life and love and memory.
Euron represents the opposite of a song – he
is silence.
His ship is named Silence, he makes people
mutes, he silences his brothers with shame,
trauma and murder.
He brings literal silence – the first time
he enters the story, “a sudden silence”
falls, and when he leaves, silence lingers.
Euron’s apocalyptic ambitions threaten to
silence the song of ice and fire itself.
And sure, the white walkers are the true danger
– but it’s Euron who’ll unleash them.
Which means the white walkers aren’t just
a magical fantasy threat – it’s more like
climate change, a threat that humans bring
onto themselves.
Book 2 and Book 3 in the series are called
A Clash of Kings and A Storm of Swords, because
they’re about war – five kings fight to
control Westeros, and thousands of people
die for them.
But all of these kings die or fail, so what
did the war achieve?
Book 4 explores the aftermath of war, and
it’s called A Feast for Crows – cause
in the end, the only people who benefit from
all the death and chaos are the outlaws and
opportunists, the monsters and betrayers who
exploit the war for their own gain – like
crows feasting on the corpse of Westeros.
The Bloody Mummers raid and rape, Lady Stoneheart
murders for vengeance, Littlefinger and the
Boltons take over kingdoms – and Euron Greyjoy
arises.
“Westeros is dying”, he says.
“Those who follow me shall feast until the
end of their days”.
Euron Crow’s Eye is the Crow of the book’s
title – an embodiment of all of the greed
cruelty and pride that drives all the conflict
of the series.
Cause like any politician, Euron isn’t dangerous
by himself – we never see him swing a sword,
or cast a spell, [he just takes drugs and
talks shit].
Euron’s powerful because people are scared
and ignorant and greedy enough to follow him
– the people chose him at the kingsmoot,
the dark lord was democratically elected.
His evil is our evil, his power comes from
the fear hope and hate inside of us – that’s
how he manipulates his family, his people,
and the world, that’s how Westeros is reduced
to corpses and crows.
So Euron’s story isn’t just about dragons
and krakens – though those bits will be
fucken sick – it’s also about how real
human impulses lead us all into self-destruction,
and silence.
So tl;dr, that goofy pirate on the dragon
show who talks about fingers in bums is actually
the most scary smart magical mysterious evil
motherfucker in Westeros – but we’ll have
to wait for the next book to see what happens
next.
George pls.
Come on George.
If you wanna truly appreciate the message
and mysteries of this story, you’ve got
to check out the books.
As well as the main series, there’s the
worldbook, and Fire and Blood, and the Dunk
and Egg stories – and you can get any one
of these on audiobook for free right now by
signing up for a trial with Audible.
Members get an audiobook each month, and if
you cancel, you keep the audiobooks.
You can listen in the car or the gym or while
you sail from Ib to Asshai.
Sign up at audible.com/asx.
Many thanks to the artists – links are all
below, and check out the linked essays and
videos for more on Euron.
This video topic was chosen by supporters
on Patreon – thanks to Patrons Nolan Strout,
Kenneth Weeks, Jess Simpson, John Padgett,
Michele Canevarolo, Scarlett Farrokh, and
Tímo.
Cheers.